[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes bonsoir à tous merci
d'être avec nous ce soir sur TV 78 pour
votre nouvelle émission le 7 8
actualités locales idée de sortie
informations pratiques voici le
programme de ce mardi 11 octobre la fête
de la science se poursuit jusqu'au 17
octobre 7 31e édition est axée sur le
changement climatique pour l'occasion la
commanderie de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
a créé un véritable village des sciences
atelier expérience rencontre avec des
scientifiques le but susciter des
vocations chez les plus jeunes nous
ferons le point sur le reste du
programme dans les Yvelines la bande
dessinée à l'honneur
au château de Bux ce weekend pour son
29e festival une cinquantaine d'auteurs
sont attendus venant de Belgique de
Suisse ou encore d'Allemagne au
programme dédicace animation et
exposition savez-vous qu'il est possible
d'écouter le brame du cerf dans les
Yvelines à l'automne tendait l'oreille
le roi de la forêt se fait entendre à la
nuit tombée un cri particulier qu'on
vous fait découvrir dans cette émission
et avec moi en plateau Maxime Morin
bonsoir alors vous êtes membre de l'IRSN
vous allez fêter la science également ce
week-end mais d'abord en quelques mots
qu'elle est quel est le qu'est-ce que
l'irfmucléaire c'est l'aput technique
des pouvoirs publics pour tout ce qui
touche le risque radioologique et
nucléaire et donc c'est un studio il
comprend à peu près 1800 personnes et
qui touche à tous les domaines du risque
nucléaire que ça soit la sûreté des
installations nucléaires leur sécurité
l'environnement ou la santé que ça soit
la santé des travailleurs du nucléaire
mais également de l'ensemble de nos
concitoyens et donc vous allez fêter la
science ce week-end puisque c'est aussi
vos 20 ans on aura le temps d'en parler
tout à l'heure dans l'émission on
parlera culture aussi et
particulièrement de bandes dessinées
avec vous Anissa bonsoir bonsoir alors
c'est le 29e festival de la BD est-ce
que ça va tout est prêt tout est prêt
non mais c'est en cours voilà
il y a beaucoup de détails à gérer mais
c'est c'est un grand bonheur voilà donc
c'est vraiment la partie magique de la
préparation le tout ce qui est en amour
et donc on parlera bien sûr du programme
tout à l'heure dans l'émission mais tout
de suite on va faire un point sur la
météo
[Musique]
demain nous fêterons la saint Wilfried
le ciel sera couvert dans les Yvelines
avec tout de même quelques éclaircies au
cours de la journée comptez 5 degrés le
matin et 16 degrés l'après-midi le temps
sera également couvert le reste de la
semaine avec des risques d'averses à
partir de samedi vous le voyez 16 degrés
à l'écran et du coup la semaine cette
semaine des risques d'averses à partir
de samedi au niveau des températures il
fera 16 degrés en moyenne
le point maintenant sur l'actualité du
jour dans les Yvelines
[Musique]
et c'est avec vous Céline sachal bonsoir
alors à la une de l'actualité toujours
les sens il faudra encore s'armer de
patience dans les prochains jours oui la
situation n'a pas changé la grève a été
reconduite ce mardi chez Total et
certaines autres stations services en
fin d'après-midi la première ministre
Elisabeth borne a tout de même annoncé
la réquisition des personnels des dépôts
des sauts exon mobile pour mettre fin à
la pénurie la préfecture des Yvelines à
quant à elle accordait ce matin un accès
prioritaire aux stations essence à
certains professionnels notamment les
professionnels de la santé pour vous
aider on vous rappelle que on a mis en
place sur les réseaux sociaux Facebook
et Twitter de la chaîne une publication
interactive où vous pouvez retrouver et
partager des informations en temps réel
sur les stations essence des Yvelines
dans les transports encore l'arrivée du
tram 13 entre Saint-Germain-en-Laye et
Saint-Cyr-l'École a provoqué une vague
de mécontentement depuis ses premiers
essais à blanc en mai dernier en cause
les nuisances sonores qui impactent les
habitants aux alentours les maires de
Bailly et Noisy-le-Roi se sont Empa du
dossier et ont adressé une lettre à
l'intention de Valérie Pécresse
présidente d’île-de-france mobilité avec
des préconisations pour remédier à cette
situation on retrouve par exemple
l'application d'une vitesse maximale à
certains endroits dans les deux communes
et l'agglomération de Rambouillet
territoire et le département des
Yvelines viennent de signer un contraste
ce matin de quoi s'agit-il Céline et oui
en fait il s'agit du contrat de
développement Yvelines plus un contrat
qui prévoit une subvention du
département de 2,81 millions d'euros les
projets concernés par cette subvention
la réhabilitation de la toiture et
l'aménagement des abords de la piscine
des fontaines à Rambouillet la
réhabilitation du pôle sportif
démoliaires aux Essarts-le-Roi le
développement d'un réseau d'équipements
loisirs et sportifs de proximité et la
création d'une micro-crèche
intercommunale à lanvilliers et enfin
les chiens auront leur propre espace à
Maurepas et oui en fait il faisait
partie du budget participatif 2021 de la
ville et était très attendu des
habitants le tout nouveau parc canin de
Maurepas peut désormais accueillir nos
amis à quatre implanter avenue de
Normandie près des jardins familiaux le
parc en accès libre se veut lieu de
sociabilisation d'entraînement adaptés
et de rencontres entre maître et chien
[Musique]
et donc on en parlait dans les titres
tout à l'heure la fête de la science a
débarqué à la Commanderie de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines le week-end
dernier au programme astronomie physique
ou encore écologique le reportage de
Céline Charles c'est un événement festif
et récurrent sur le territoire de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines le village des
sciences est revenu ce week-end à la
Commanderie il proposait cette année une
trentaine d'activités avec des stands
des présentations de projets ou encore
des spectacles l'objectif c'est vraiment
de diffuser à être vulgariser la culture
scientifique les sciences ça fait peur
notamment comme je vous disais on est
sur la thématique du changement
climatique donc ça on entend beaucoup ça
pose beaucoup de questions l'idée ici
c'est vraiment de rendre accessible ses
connaissances au plus large public
observation du soleil imprimante 3D
exposition sur la physique et la chimie
le village des sciences et l'occasion de
venir à la rencontre des scientifiques
artistes et associations
qui vous présentera un stand vous avez
des associations naturaliste
scientifique vous avez aussi des
universités de l'Université de
Versailles Saint-Quentin vient avec des
étudiantes justement pour présenter ça
aujourd'hui easys nous sommes
présents sur certaines problématiques
qu'on traite chez Egis donc typiquement
on a ramené avec nous une maquette
lambouste donc le Lambus c'est une
solution qui permet d'offrir un habitat
immédiat à la biodiversité tous types
d'animaux donc des oiseaux des
coccinelles des abeilles des mulots on a
aussi une maquette hydraulique en Lego
cette année le radioclub amateur de 50
ans en Yvelines a implanté une antenne
sur le parking objectif permettre des
communications radio en direct sur un
tiers de la planète une activité
radioamateur via un satellite
géostationnaire on peut communiquer
d'ici depuis
Élancourt au Pôle Nord au pôle sud à
l'est vers l'Europe de l'Est et un peu
plus loin l'Inde et à l'ouest vers le
Brésil la Fête de la Science s'étend
jusqu'au 17 octobre d'autres activités
sont proposées dans les médiathèques de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines prochain
rendez-vous un spectacle sur la
circonférence des particules à la
médiathèque de Nautilus à Villepreux
et Céline vous y étiez alors qu'est-ce
que vous en avez pensé est-ce que vous
avez appris des choses je le vois je
vous avouer que j'ai fait un petit tour
des stands moi aussi que j'ai appris
beaucoup de choses notamment les
différents minéraux par exemple qui
alimentent nos véhicules électriques ou
bien comment faire plusieurs objets avec
une imprimante 3D qu'on peut retrouver
au skyblade au Skylab de trap et aussi
un bon plan si vous êtes comment un
petit peu allergique au pollen j'ai
découvert une application qui s'appelle
live pollen disponible sur tous les
téléphones et en fait elle donne
l'information des mesures du pollen en
temps réel et à proximité d'accord super
intéressant merci Céline pour l'info
pour retrouver le programme complet
rendez-vous sur le site internet de la
commanderie de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
et autres lieux de sciences c'est l'IRSN
Maxime Morin alors vous allez ouvrir vos
portes ce week-end pourquoi pourquoi
faire découvrir au grand public ce lieu
de sciences alors l'idée c'est déjà de
partager nos activités puisque l'IRAC
est ainsi que public donc c'est normal
qu'on aille aussi vers les citoyens
sur un domaine qui n'est pas forcément
très connu ou en tout cas pas connu dans
sa globalité le nucléaire d'autant plus
dans une région qui est peu nucléarisée
qui est l'Île-de-France en pratique
hormis quelques sites comme un Saclay au
sud dans l'Essonne donc l'idée c'est
vraiment d'aller vers les gens et de les
accompagner à la fois pour les informer
sur le risque nucléaire sur le nucléaire
plus généralement le fonctionnement
d'une centrale nucléaire les différents
types d'accidents nucléaires sur ton
contexte aujourd'hui qui peut être un
peu anxiogène et puis c'est de leur
faire partager plus généralement les
travaux de scientifiques dans le domaine
aussi bien de la physique de la radio
chimie de l'assurance de l'environnement
de la santé vous allez proposer
plusieurs démonstrations donc vous
parlez de vos travaux concrètement
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que les gens
vont pouvoir apprendre alors il y aura
plusieurs activités sur le site il y
aura des activités plutôt dédiées aux
enfants où là on va plutôt être sur des
sur des activités de type un petit peu
de chimie de base comment on utilise un
acide comment est-ce qu'on a différents
types de fluides qu'on va pouvoir qu'on
va pouvoir utiliser on va également
faire visiter nos laboratoires donc
aussi bien dans le domaine de
environnement que dans le domaine de la
santé donc les gens pourront voir
notamment certains moyens de crise de
contrôle des personnes de la
contamination des personnes ou voir le
plus grand parc métrologique d'Europe
puisque c'est à eau Vésinet qu'on a une
grande partie de nos laboratoires
environnementaux pour l'analyse des
échantillons y compris pour des
microtraces de radioactivité alors ce
qu'on a des événements qui peuvent se
produire à travers le monde d'accord et
du coup c'est aussi l'occasion pour le
public de rencontrer des chercheurs je
suppose oui tout à fait sur le site
participeront quasiment uniquement des
personnels scientifiques des techniciens
des ingénieurs des personnes qui
réalisent de la recherche et sous la
forme soit d'un dialogue au travers de
l'exposition de l'URSS et d'autorité de
sortie nucléaire qui présentent
justement en différents panneaux les
différents aspects du nucléaire et des
risques associés au nucléaires ou
directement à l'intérieur des
laboratoires et c'est les personnes qui
travaillent dans ses laboratoires qui
présenteront les outils de recherche les
outils d'expertise à notre disposition
oui donc vous le disiez c'est un lieu un
peu insolite on va pouvoir visiter vos
laboratoires vos équipements il me
semble qu'il y a une voiture un véhicule
qui permet de détecter la radioactivité
d'une ou de plusieurs personnes est-ce
que vous pouvez nous en dire un peu plus
tout à fait donc un véhicule d'anthropo
gamavétrie en langage un petit peu
compliqué c'est des véhicules qui
permettent de mesurer la contamination
interne des personnes soit en situation
normale pour du suivi de travailleur par
exemple soit en situation accidentelle
si d'aventure on devait avoir à
contrôler la population civile ou des
intervenants sur le site et à ce moment
là on peut détecter assez rapidement les
niveaux de contamination de ces
personnes contamination interne puisque
c'est facile d'accéder c'est plus facile
d'accéder à la contamination externe en
revanche une fois qu'elle est ingée on
pense notamment à l'iode à ce moment là
c'est plus compliqué mais donc le but de
ce camion c'est de fournir un résultat
pour évaluer la dose engagée de ces
personnes
si vous détectez quelqu'un ce week-end
comment ça se passe alors normalement ça
ne devrait pas arriver mais à ce
moment-là il sera pris en charge
évidemment comme comme tout examen qui
est résident ce camion il est pris en
charge par un médecin d'accord et ce
qu'il y a des risques dans sur le
territoire des Yvelines de radioactivité
ou alors la radioactivité elle est
partout autour de nous donc il y a la
radioactivité naturelle bien entendu à
laquelle on est tous exposé et qui est
responsable de la majorité de ce qu'on
appelle la dose de chaque citoyen
français avec des différences entre les
citoyens entre les fumeurs et les
non-fumeurs entre les forts
consommateurs de de fruits de mer par
exemple et ceux qui n'en consomment pas
en pratique il y a pas de grande
installation nucléaire à proximité des
Yvelines le les centres nucléaires sont
plutôt dans l'Essonne et donc c'est pour
ça que ça serait très surprenant de
découvrir quelqu'un parmi la population
en revanche il y a quand même un autre
aspect c'est les examens médicaux par
exemple et donc lorsqu'on passe une
scintigraphie à ce moment-là on injecte
des produits radioactifs dans le corps
pour poser un diagnostic médical et là
on peut éventuellement détecter on
détecte si des personnes exercices
scintigraphie à ce moment-là à l'aide de
ce camion par exemple on verrait qu'ils
ont été exposés à des radios nucléides
est-ce que vous pouvez nous rappeler
quels sont les risques pour la santé et
pour l'environnement de la radioactivité
alors la radioactivité elle va avoir
plusieurs effets les effets des
rayonnements c'est principalement quand
on parle de l'être humain les effets sur
l'organisme il y a différents types
d'expositions ça peut être une
exposition dite d'irradiation c'est à
dire je suis exposé à des rayonnements
c'est ce qui est utilisé notamment dans
le cadre des radiothérapies à ce
moment-là ça va être un risque pour
l'ADN c'est-à-dire avoir des cassures
des destructions de cellules ce qui peut
occasionner par exemple des cancers à
plus long terme et on peut avoir aussi
des risques liés de contamination
interne donc on va ingérer des produits
radioactifs et là aussi on va avoir des
dégâts sur les différents tissus qui
sont qui sont à gérer au niveau du corps
humain alors le principal risque que les
gens connaissent au niveau naturel c'est
le radon donc un gaz qui est dégagé par
certains types de roches qui ont des
descendants d'uranium et à ce moment là
on va être exposé au descendants du
radon et donc on va avoir une exposition
qui est liée au sol et puis un autre
risque les gens très bien qu'il risque
naturel aussi c'est les rayonnements
cosmiques et donc on va être exposé à
des flux qui sont issus des étoiles qui
sont issues de tous les objets qu'on
trouve dans l'univers et on va avoir
formation aussi dans l'atmosphère sous
l'effet de rayonnement de différents de
différents radios nuclées et c'est pour
ça par exemple que quand on prend
l'avion et bien on a une dose engagée un
peu plus élevée puisqu'on est plus haut
et donc on est plus exposé à ces
rayonnements cosmiques merci beaucoup
Maxime Morin vous nous avez appris plein
de choses ce soir merci d'être venu en
parler avec nous sur ce plateau et donc
vous pourrez retrouver toutes les
informations sur les portes ouvertes
Dieu de l'URSS pardon sur leur site
internet et on continue de parler de
science comme chaque année le Prix
L'Oréal l'UNESCO repris récompense des
chercheuses pour valoriser l'excellence
scientifique cette année encore une
yvelinoise et récompensée Tina nikuka et
doctorante en mathématiques appliquée à
l'École normale supérieure Paris-Saclay
elle travaille sur le traitement de
l'image Mélanie poquet à sa rencontre
en quelques clics des algorithmes
prouvent que cette image est falsifiée
parmi eux celui créé par une jeune
yvelinoise Tina nicuka et doctorante en
mathématiques appliquées le but de ma
recherche c'est de créer des algorithmes
qui donc sont capables de savoir ce qui
est arrivé à une image et donc dans
détecter les anomalies donc c'est une
image je sais qu'il est qu'elle a subi
telle opération parce que l'image subit
une suite d'opération mathématiques si
je sais qu'elle a subi telle opération
particulière je peux voir localement
dans l'image s'il y a des parties qui
n'ont pas subi la même opération un
algorithme développé au sein du Centre
Borély laboratoire de l'École normale
supérieure de Paris Saclay est mis en
pratique avec l'Agence France Presse
bien loin de la recherche en blouse
blanche Tina Nico fait partie des
chercheuses distinguées de la 16ème
édition du plus jeune talent France de
la Fondation L'Oréal
ce prix c'est une reconnaissance de ma
recherche mais encore plus de ce que je
fais en dehors de la recherche classique
j'ai pas je pense pas avoir ce prix
parce que j'ai soumis des conférences
j'ai des articles je pense que j'ai
supprimé pour
l'étape en plus que j'ai fait de
transmettre les sciences au grand public
Tina nicuka va bientôt soutenir sa thèse
prochain défi de la doctorante et de son
laboratoire travailler sur les deep fake
des trucs à utiliser l'intelligence
artificielle
et la fête de la science c'est aussi à
l'OVSQ toute la semaine auront lieu des
ateliers des rencontres entre citoyens
et scientifiques aujourd'hui le
climatologue est prix Nobel de la paix
avec le GIEC Jean jauzelle était présent
pour présenter son documentaire
Jean-Joseph dans la bataille du siècle
l'interview de Gabriel Gontier
[Musique]
je crois que ça fait partie de notre
rôle que d'aller vers les gens donc je
pense qu'il faut absolument communiquer
la fête de la science est un bon exemple
de communication vers les jeunes alors
peut-être dans la Fête de la Science moi
vers les éditeurs politiques si possible
vers le grand public c'est toujours
assez difficile mais j'ai toujours
considéré que que disons communiqué nos
résultats les faire savoir alors c'est
important de le faire aussi au sein de
notre communauté de rédiger des articles
scientifiques mais il faut absolument
aussi mettre ses résultats je dirais
apporter de tous les publics
ce qui m'intéressait c'est de faire
comprendre en quoi l'étude des climats
passés nous apporter des informations
très pertinentes pour l'évolution future
du climat je me suis intéressé disons
bien sûr je suis beaucoup impliqué dans
le GIEC je me suis beaucoup impliqué
dans les dans toutes les conventions
climat j'ai participé depuis 20 ans donc
à travers cette histoire on peut
effectivement et c'était le l'objectif
de la documentariste raconter la prise
de conscience et je crois que c'est le
fil rouge de la prise de conscience de
la réalité de réchauffement climatique
et c'est ça je crois l'intérêt de ce
documentaire
l'action c'est aujourd'hui et donc les
jeunes qui rentrent vous êtes aussi
concernés par l'action à la fois par
l'inaction et par l'action et voilà et
moi j'encourage mais c'est vrai pour
toutes les générations à l'action aussi
bien dans la vie
on a de l'action dans sa vie je dirais
de citoyens habite tous les jours quand
on regarde les recommandations de
citoyens se déplaçaient se nourrir se
loger c'est notre vie de tous les jours
mais aussi je pense sincèrement pour
tous les jeunes qui s'engagent dans le
monde du travail et bien il y a pas de
secteurs d'activités qui puisse se dire
que le réchauffement climatique ce n'est
pas son affaire
[Musique]
la Fête de la Science continue à
l'observatoire de l'Université de
Versailles
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines retrouvé
toutes les activités sur leur site
internet on va parler culture maintenant
et plus particulièrement de BD
[Musique]
le château de Buc accueillait un atelier
bande dessinée avec des personnes
placées sous main de justice une
coopération entre le service
pénitentiaire d'insertion et de
probation et la municipalité c'était
dans le cadre de la 29e édition du
Festival de la bande dessinée de Buc le
reportage de Patrick Jacques de Dixmude
et Maxent
bien c'est que tout le monde a travaillé
pratiquement sur les sur les vignettes
là en fait et donc chacun apporté un bas
de sa personne et de ce qui savait le
mieux faire des personnes places c'est
souvent justice initié à la bande
dessinée cet événement se tenait pour la
quatrième fois au château de Buc comme
professeur le dessinateur et rock
scénariste de la BD les profs qui
animait cet atelier auprès de Damien et
des 7 autres participants c'est un
milieu assez attractif c'est un lieu
créatif et ça peut aussi éveiller des
passions pour certaines personnes ah ça
se passe très bien c'est un on peut dire
c'est un très bon professeur
un exercice passionnant aussi bien pour
les participants que pour l'animateur
qui ont vraiment été moteur pendant les
deux jours parce que très forte en
dessin finalement c'est parfois un
hasard mais voilà là c'est le cas on a
des férus de BD qui reviennent voilà
donc c'est c'est plutôt plaisant
l'adolescence crie dans le cadre de la
vente neuvième édition du festival BD au
château de Buc le travail réalisé les
participants sera exposé les 15 et 16
octobre prochain lors de l'événement
et justement on va parler du festival de
la BD avec vous Anissa bonsoir rebonsoir
merci de nous accueillir vous êtes
responsable de la culture à Buc alors
c'est la 29e édition
c'est important pour la ville
parlez-nous un qu'est-ce que ça
représente pour la commune alors le
festival BD est un des événements phares
de la ville c'est un événement qui est
né qui a commencé tout petit et puis qui
a évolué dans le temps et puis le
reportage qui convient de voir et
vraiment révélateur de ce qu'on aime
vraiment que ce festival de Vienne
c'est-à-dire un festival qui fait d'air
qui amène les gens autour d'une
thématique et la BD et comme j'aime à le
dire c'est une c'est un outil redoutable
puisque c'est un outil qui nous permet
d'aller vers
toutes les catégories d'âge et puis de
pouvoir réunir autour de quelque chose
donc au delà de la dédicace dont on a
parlé souvent c'est un festival qui tend
qui va vers ça je dirais l'âge mature ou
maintenant il commence à rayonner sur le
territoire et puis surtout à proposer
des projets il commence aussi à produire
c'est à dire que il a pris le temps je
ferai peut-être la comparaison avec un
enfant qui a été chéri et puis
aujourd'hui c'est tout tout cet amour
toute cette passion qu'il a qu'il a
qu'il a qu'il a eu et bien aujourd'hui
elle doit rejaillir et c'est vrai qu'on
fait pas mal de choses autour du
territoire je dirais le festival BD
vient simplement ponctuer un temps fort
et il se veut aussi la mort d'un projet
qu'on veut développer tout le long de
l'année et surtout le territoire voilà
donc c'est vraiment en tout cas notre
souhait et alors parlez-nous un peu de
la programmation quelle est-elle cette
année alors la programmation
généralement elle est elle est elle est
comment dire elle est sur trois axes
bien sûr l'axe culturel donc avec la
dédicace avec
l'accueil des comment dire des auteurs
toutes les animations qu'on peut avoir
aussi autour de la thématique BD mais
aussi un axe je dirais pédagogique
sociale on va utiliser cet outil comme
c'est le cas de du dans le reportage
qu'on vient de voir où l'on va essayer
d'utiliser en fait
la BD comme un outil pour aller vers des
publics qu'on dit empêcher ou qui n'ont
pas
et donc avec l'idée bien sûr de de
reprendre confiance de vivre une
expérience unique c'est vraiment des
retrouvailles il y a pas de performance
artistique en soi et puis petit à petit
on se rend compte que les gens en fait
comment ça s'ouvrir et à démontrer en
fait leur capacités parce qu'on a tous
des capacités que ce soit les enfants
les jeunes les adultes le tout c'est
d'aller les chercher et avec le bon
moyen voilà et donc du coup il y a cet
axe là qu'on développe beaucoup beaucoup
et c'est vrai que dans ce domaine là et
bien la municipalité le porte-à-vous de
bras aussi les institutions parce que on
propose des projets aussi qui sont
soutenus financièrement par des
institutions privées et publiques et
qu'on remercie beaucoup parce que c'est
un grand gros enfin c'est un gros
travail
d'abord de collecte de fonds
d'organisation de mise en place et puis
à l'axe patrimonial ou effectivement
c'est vrai que c'est un festival qu'on a
délocalisé au sein du château de Buc
pourquoi parce que on veut transmettre
une histoire l'histoire de la ville
l'histoire de la ville elle est très
très riche et le château en est
l'emblème et c'est aussi on en profite
beaucoup de la thématique BD en tout cas
pour la transmettre au bu quoi et on
oublie quoi puisque c'est vrai que Buck
a une histoire très très riche voilà
votre rapport vous à la BD Maxime Morin
des auteurs préférés peut-être ouh là
moi je oui
moins qu'avant j'avais eu j'étais plutôt
les grands les grands noms connus j'aime
bien Franck Miller notamment et puis bon
comme on parlait de Buc edgarpé Jacobs
évidemment en lien avec Buck mais c'est
la prédestinée
Tintin plus petit mais ça c'est plus
partagé mais c'est vrai que j'en lis un
peu moins maintenant
et vous Céline des auteurs préférées
[Rires]
Gaston Lagaffe voilà ça c'est ce que je
disais quand j'étais quand j'étais
enfant finalement
et bien merci beaucoup Anissa et puis
nous vous attendons nombreux ce weekend
mais j'ai plus qu'à vous souhaiter bon
festival merci beaucoup merci est-ce que
Céline vous avez déjà entendu le brame
du cerf je peux cette chanson mais
apparemment c'est un rugissement assez
rock c'est ça c'est assez surprenant
est-ce que autour de la table Anissa
Maxime non non plus alors sachez que bah
si vous vous baladez en forêt le
week-end à l'automne particulièrement
enfin c'est de fin août jusqu'à fin
octobre vous pourrez entendre ce cri
particulier du roi de la forêt Solène
Boivin guide nature pour le parc
régional de la Haute Vallée de Chevreuse
vous emmène à la nuit tombée pour une
expérience unique avec Gabriel Gonthier
nous avons eu la chance de l'accompagner
savez-vous
identifier ce bruit
de fin août jusqu'à octobre le cerf se
fait entendre à la nuit tombée il s'agit
du brame un cri facilement
reconnaissable durant la période de
reproduction du cervidé ce soir on a eu
vraiment beaucoup de chance parce que
on a donc on est vraiment resté sur sur
un chemin communal et à côté de nous on
a pu entendre pas mal de cerfs il y en
avait trois quatre qui bramait à ses
proches on a pu
identifier plusieurs brame il y avait
notamment le un brame de longueur c'est
celui qui
est long
à langoureux
c'est celui qui va vraiment
asseoir le cerf sur sur sa place
autour du de cette place il va y avoir
toutes les biches qui vont gravité mais
pour Solène le plus important c'est de
faire de la pédagogie avec les personnes
présentes grâce à des quiz des photos ou
encore des ossements par exemple
que les mygales ça faisait des
chaussettes aussi que les
servent à aller dans les propriétés
privées c'était super cela nous a bien
expliqué déjà l'environnement ce qu'on
allait voir le brame du cerf mais
c'était très sympa ouais marcher dans la
nuit comme ça sans lumière c'est en fait
on sait pas les mêmes sens qui qui
travaillent et du coup c'est vraiment
sympa
si vous souhaitez découvrir le brame du
cerf attention il y a quelques règles à
respecter ne vous écartez pas des
chemins forestiers autorisés soyez le
plus discret possible sans lumière et ne
cherchez pas à vous approcher des
animaux le brame est avant tout une
période d'écoute
une expérience vraiment unique que je
vous recommande et juste avant de vous
laisser on va refaire un point sur la
météo
[Musique]
demain nous fêterons la saint Wilfried
le ciel sera couvert dans les Yvelines
avec tout de même quelques éclaircies au
cours de la journée comptez 5 degrés le
matin et 16 degrés l'après-midi le temps
sera également couvert le reste de la
semaine avec des risques d'averses à
partir de samedi au niveau des
températures il fera 16 degrés en
moyenne 21 le lundi
et c'est la fin de cette émission merci
d'avoir été avec nous sur TV 78 on se
retrouve demain pour une édition
spéciale pour le salon des mers de
l'Ouest parisien en attenant prenez bien
soin de vous et à bientôt je vous
souhaite une belle soirée sur TV 78
[Musique]